Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to POPGOES.
I'm going back in; I have no plan, I've come up with nothing, to fix this or beat this, I have no idea...
I don't know how the BaAAaadger works,
But I've just gotta play "badger badger badger" on loop until it goes away.
Do I gotta like put on a badger suit blend in with the Badgers?
I don't know what I gotta do, if you tell me I could do it. I don't know (Marki-chuckle)
It's so not explanatory! How do we do any of this?
It was some kind of battery thing, I ran out of power!
That's what it looked like, but I don't even know how I do the power thing!
Like what are the powers mean? What are the colors? I don't know the colors :(
UUHH I don't know
(picks up the phone) Fritz: Right... Hello again
F: I think I should start off this call by pointing out that I actually made a mistake
F: In my previous message, which was yesterday's main recording to you (Mark: oh god, I'm already panicked D:)
F: I said that the heaters in the vents stayed on for a minute when you turn them on...
F: .... In reality... I made it closer to like... (M:  *exasperated sigh*)
F: 9 seconds or something
M: OH SHUT UP
(Intense silence and switching cameras)
Ah shit. How I- Oh god. I'm so not doing GUAEH! Oh hi, okay
Sorry to interrupt you, you carry on, you do your thing, you do your thing buddy, okay? He's gone. Great. Good. Oh, what did you do?
What was that?!
What you doing there?!
What we-?!
Excuse me? Why were you there?
Wher- What did the Badger doing there?!
What th- hell?! Yellow call the- Ah FUCK not that! CALL THE BADGER
I don't- Ahh okay, I don't know what I did, but I think I helped it. I'm not 100% sure- WOAH No no no no AH GOD DAMNIT
Ahh fu- UHE-EY!
Hi, I called y- uh, I'm gonna look away now
Ooh, mysterious how that badger just appeared out of nowhere. I don't know what that is all about but- you still there?
Oh great. It's uh yellow and-
Alright, see ya!
Okay alright!
Don't like that, don't like that at all. I'm gonna go with a big old NO on that one.
I want to go with "Uh, I hate that,
"that's awful, and don't do that". A big ol "fuck you go away forever, and uh die" that'd be... that'd be lovely if you
Did that...
Yeeeeeesh, why is my panic not going away? Why is my pamy-namy-ehn okay, it's going down okay, all right, whatever.
Ah, it shut down! Oh, I finally caught one of you, you freaking asshole. Well. You know where the other girls are??
Where all the ladies at??
I dunno.
Frick a dick- oh my god.
This is insanity. How would you do any of this? This is only the third night?
I'm only at 1 AM. Stop that! Where's it? Oh, there you are, okay, well I got you staying down for 10 seconds.
Whatever. HEY. Stop that! No? Well, I can't do anything about that. I'm gonna go with green...
Call badger...
Hi..? Hello, well (nervous chuckle) you know
Alrighty, then well. I'll see you okay. You just have a goo-ood ol time there. Gonna...
Pretend like you aren't there >_>
Doodly-doo there's no badger behind me doodly-doo. I'm totally fine. Yeah, doodlee okay it's gone... okay good
Where is the other guy? Man, this is a NIGHTMARE
Don't- NO! ou get heated! Get gone! Banished by the power of HEEAAATTTT
Never thought I'd have my heat transferred into weapon form for animatronics...
Not really weapons, more like defensive armor you get- don't do that.
Whatever you're doing, whatever you're conspiring for, just don't do it. Aye. That's pink. I got you. CALL THE BADGER
I've got a badger...problem....probably to my left. Yep.
I got a badger, okay! Welp, that's a thing that I deal with.....
....eventually.....
Just gonna ignore that problem. Bury It deep down. It'll never arise again right? (nope) Nope! You're still there! (told you).
Wow, how about that. You'll kill me? I think this badgers gonna kill me!
I don't need to worry about anything else killing me when I've got a badger on-call. (nervous laugh) you still there? Oh good.
Okay, he's gone. Alrighty then. Sorry, sorry. What a helpful badger (lies)
Where's this guy go? He's gone. What-
don't kill me. I don't even know what I'm doing. How do you have so many goddamn pieces?
Where the frick are you being even? (That made no sense, Mark.)
Where are you even the being? Stop,  go nowhere. Do the opposite of movement.
Just eat dicks. I don't care. God Dammit. Did you get another piece? YOU GOT ANOTHER PIECE!
HOW'D YOU GET ANOTHER PIECE?! Stop getting sho- shor- so efficient, like capture the flag (war flashbacks)
Fuck you. Whoa- I saw that! In the vent camera. OooOOooh you get heat. Okay, I'm never gonna survive this. It's only 2:00 a.m.
How the fuck...
How would anybody? How should anybody? How could anybody? I just gotta- what I gotta
do is I gotta be more efficient about my, uh, panic time. Right? You know what I mean, you know what
I'm talking about, you know what I'm slith slayin', you know I'm say sizzlin'.
Yeah, you know what I'm sayin. I just gotta keep my panic down. That way I'm less stupid about everything that I'm doing...
You...
gotta heat up... got that... so that's the... the other key. You just gotta get those as often as possible.
Okay, green, call, okay, I got a badger, you get shut down. You're there. Well alright hello, okay.
Hedoodly, okay, doodlee. Okay? All right? Well you're there. I'm gonna look over here now
All right, where'd you go? You still in there? Good, you stay there...
okay..
Mmm.. He's... Oh, OH OHH- Got ya!
Okay ~panic panic panic, gonna panic away, panicking away all my problems~
doodle-oda-loo doodily-do doodle-oda-odaly-doo
Okay...
Still in there? Good. Heat? Okay.
Keep'n my down. The badger's back.
"Ma'am, I got a serious badger problem"
"Can you fix this? Nooo?"
Get heEeAat!
Blue?
Oh, he's sucking my power right out of me.
I don't know if I need to check on you, but I'm doing it just to be polite.
I don't want someone just staring at me out of the blue. You know? You still there? Alright ladies, who gets some /heat/
Still there- oh! (nervous chuckle)
How ya doin, okay. Well that's a
thing that happens and exists in this world...
But I got a better lock on this, now that I got a rhythm and a pattern going on.
Kind of doing a little better- HEAT, okay.
And by HEAT I mean DeAdLy
LaSeRs!!!1!!11 Where have you gone? I know you're somewhere here. Nope. Apparently not.
Get that panic down! He likes that one. He likes that one. He really likes that one. He really likes that one, and I don't know why.
Personally I think it's a little...
...contrived.
Funky dunky. Call the badger. No. I don't know if I'm gonna make it this time. It's only 3 a.m.
But I'm doin better- hi Badgy. How you doin? Ok, good for you. (some kind of Slavic accent??)
What the fuck, I saw Chica??!
Did you guys just- no not not that, not thaaaAAt- okay got that, got that, he doesn't have another part.
Doesn't have another part...
Doing good there, get the panic down, you need heat, okay.
What- he /really/ likes that one. I think I got a lucky streak here, because he only goes to the same one over and over again.
But then he's gonna trick me on that one, and it's not gonna be as easy :c
~thunk~ Okay. I got him locked down pretty good there...
Did I see chica again? >_>
Yeah, he wants...he wants that one.
Maybe it's like...maybe it's like he can only get a body part from certain ones of them (nice grammar), and the fact that I currently
right now have both of them on...like on lock...
Like they're both in the same spot, so it kind of works out real good-ly for me. You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, it kind of works out real nice-like, you know? I mean, not that a few other button presses wouldn't be too bad
But, you know, so long as I don't have to look at anything else I mean
Whoops. Oh shit. Oh fuck no that and that okay, ughhh
As long as I don't flip up the Button Boopers™
Booper scooper, give me that pink, boink doink, that sounded weird, but you know I'm gonna stick with that- DOINK okay.
Yeah
I think it is; I think he only gets certain body parts from certain places, and therefore if he can't
If he can't get it from one, he's just gonna keep going back to it, right? (Right)
That's what makes sense. I think anyway... so he needs like, uh,
Does he need the body? He needs the body and the head.
So what that means is that must be either the body or the head printer.
Double-checking just to be sure.
You never know with this ASSHOLE!
Yeah, he's there.
Locked, loaded,
Locked and loaded...
Oh, what are you doing? What's the color? Oh, bloop, bloink. Ello! You're quick!
Response time is amazing with this guy!
Ok
5 a.m.. If I keep this up, I think I WIIINNN. I think I win one!! Hey, you still there- ok. That's weird.
You can- you can ~go about now~
It's like when you call a repairman to your apartment, and they just kinda ~hang out~ for WAY too long- you still there?
Buddy? Okay, good. Alright. Good thing you fucked off
Really appreciate that, that's my favorite part of the day is when you fuck off (harsh)
Aye-aye-aye-aye...
NO!! EAT DICKS! AHH! GET OUTTA HERE! HEEAAAT! LAAASERS!
right a little more a little more a little more come on give it to me
Give it to meee! (Lovely singing, Mark.)
Lasers? double lasers? epic ultra laser combo! don't do any of that. you're still in there? Okay, He's not in there
aAAAH! HOW MUCH MORE DO I HAVE LEFT?? Gimme a heaty lazer! Gimme a heaty lazer!
Okay. We go that outta the way
NOOO! Stop that! :<
Okay, no God it clicked out the game. Ahh, i hope that didn't break absolutely fucking everything I bet it did
Heat okay, okay panic down and then we're good to go
HEEEY! EH- OH DE- OH DE DA I DID IT! THAT LOOKS LIKE SESAME STREET! YAY! WHOO! Ahh...
All right, let's see what other horrible nightmare is awaiting me in the land of the tentacles and veins
aye-aye-aye-aye
You be- oh look at this chubby cheeked piece of garbage! Yeah, let's see where you're going
Are you a weasel or are you Blake the Badger?
I don't know and frankly I don't care
I'm gonna go see if I need to say hi to Chica, which should be up and to the right maybe
up and straight would be good
I don't exactly know. I'll find out oh, it's open the path is open to me. So this is what it is
I gotta find all of them in there horrible
horrible prison of death and
Badness oh no oh no. That's her beak. Oh, that's her beak. That was her beak and her bib on the floor
Greatest combo I could think of
Hi Chica! okay well alright those are all the toy versions. That's the interesting thing to think about this
Those are all the toy versions so whoever made these pop-goes things is
The same creator of all those toy versions of the animatronics
Because if you know five nights at Freddy's 2 and the toy versions were there is actually in the past
So those weren't made by the same person that made the original so I think that's what pop-goes is going for like this is an
Offshoot all right how am I gonna die? Oh look at these cute figurines? I'm gonna immediately start into this aren't I?
[phone ringing] What?!
[phone ringing] Whaaaaaaaaat?!
[phone ringing] WAT??
Fritz: Hello again! I've decided to take some breaks between recording these calls... Not many are left but still,
I didn't think it would be this stressful... I've just got some notes, not a script or anything. I feel like i might be talking too much
about things that are obvious to you, so I'm just gonna wing this one.
I think at this point you must be pretty confident with your job now. If you can even call it that. (Mark: Naaah)
I think now might be a good time for you to know a little more about me. I have a feeling you might be curious. Am i wrong?
Yes, you are!
Great then. I was born in November, 1968 in Texas. (Mark: Don't care.) With a difficult life up until my teen years (Mark: I really don't care -_-)
I had some real problems with my family but we weren't exactly rich. My father was an architect at the time and my mother stayed home with my brother and I.
Until the 80s we lived in a flat... Or... I suppose it would have been called an apartment over there... It was pretty decent, I think but, honestly, I cant remember much.
I had an accident in my teens, stuff I... really don't wanna talk about, please don't ask. (Mark: WASN'T GONNA. -_-) I might explain in a later call or something
If there is.... Uh (Mark: Geez...) Time... Anyway, fortunately, I did survive the injury, believe it or not...
It was all down to a very generous doner... (Mark: Believe it or not?!)
The whole thing was pretty strange and big for us and all I know is a small team of people, maybe it was one person, who was willing to give tons of blood to the hospital
and offered an entire encyclopedia of signed papers, the transfusion was allowed on behalf of the procedure being an experiment.. I was close to death bare in mind...
I lost most of my memory from before the incident and the whole event caused a huge stir in the media
I was eighteen. And with the state i was in, paparazzi wasn't the best treatment, Y'know?
So I sorted something out with my parents and they moved here to England.. So... Hopefully on top of being a security guard you can be a friend too..
I've wanted to get somethings (Mark: GOD DAMMIT!) off my chest for a while... And uh... I don't have many people to share them with...
And my daughter's kind of busy most of the time. Just someone for me to talk to... And of course, listen to. So, go ahead. What do you want to talk about?
(Mark's lost for words.) What else have you made?? Fritz: What else have I made? Hmm. Well this recording system has over five hours left on it but...
(Mark: I SAW THAT, FREDDY!) That still won't go over everything I've made... It's been a hell of a good hobby for over a decade now.
I'm trying to go over some of the more interesting things though
In 2019 I made a self driving car in my garage. The technology isn't that impressive now-a-days, I know but it was an amazing feat.
Looked like garbage but it worked. Since then, it's been modified to be road safe and now my daughter uses it. Back in the late 90s I made a few electric guitars, sold them to a secondary school (High school)
And in 2016 i  made a video game with Bonnie's help... Oh, Bonnie is the name of my daughter, not sure if I mentioned that (Mark: BAHHHHT??)
Oh and, of course I made the 3D printers recently which help me print smaller, plastic parts for projects and toys and whatnot.
That's really it, don't think I should mention anything else right now. Hope that clears it up. (Mark: THAT DOESN'T CLEAR ANYTHING UP! THAT CLEARS NOTHING UP!)
Oh fuck he's already got another piece of the shadow bon. Oh, I'm boned
I AM PANICKING! I DON'T EVEN KNOW-
Hi, okay alright, sorry did I interrupt you I'll look away now. Thank you for being an asshole
Badger have you been there the whole time
Fucking weasel bitch you fucking asshole weasel piece of shit ya- you douche with your stupid
Scavenger hunt of bullshit using technology, you know this is this the future
We're all looking forward to a bunch of robots being assholes and then making more of themselves
That's what we can look forward to all this technology Elon Musk, and all the shit. They're just going for this
You know they're all doing it's like it's not a you know. It's not even it's not even cool. It's just like stupid right oh
I didn't even see you making that you piece of ass
Fuck you is what I'm trying to say is a whole bunch of bullshit, and I don't like you with your stupid fastness
Why are you fast?
Where are you? oh, Hi, Hello. Whelp is friendly over here? How can I see a little bit of you? Well oh?
Why was the badger that- whaaaat?
That's-, I don't like that that is not good I
Don't have a phone
WELP... I'm fucked! AYE!
Wow my brain got munched well
Also what's with this connection lost thing right?
am I a robot?
am I a robot? I might be a robot anyway. That's all the time. I got for this now
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down the comments below
I will finish this very soon and as always I will see you
in the next video. BUH-BYEE!